(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Na aula anterior, nós aprendemos as duas modalidades
de leilão, que são os leilões judiciais e
os leilões extrajudiciais.
Nessa aula, nós vamos aprender quais são os
tipos de leilão, ou seja, quais são as
formas que um leilão pode ser realizado.
O leilão, ele pode ser realizado de forma
online, de forma presencial e de forma híbrida,
que vai ser a realização simultânea do leilão
online e do leilão presencial.
Vamos começar com os leilões online.
Os leilões online, eles ganharam muita força por
ter uma facilidade de realização e uma facilidade
para atrair interessados, porque veja, esse leilão online,
ele tem o procedimento realizado todo de forma
online, então é muito simples para qualquer pessoa
participar.
Basta ter um acesso à internet, que aquela
pessoa vai poder se cadastrar e realizar lances
naquele leilão.
E também, eles possuem uma facilidade de atrair
interessados.
Veja, é muito mais fácil que um leiloeiro,
ele coloque um link e peça para a
pessoa entrar naquele link, do que ele divulgue
um leilão e peça para alguém comparecer presencialmente.
Hoje em dia, o mundo é todo digital,
então as pessoas preferem, obviamente, o leilão online.
A preferência pelo leilão online é tanta, que
a lei fala claramente que o leilão judicial
deve ser preferencialmente realizado de forma online.
Então, hoje em dia, o leilão judicial, ele
vai ser realizado, basicamente, de forma online.
Existem algumas poucas exceções em que o leilão,
ele ainda é realizado de forma presencial.
E no leilão ex-judicial, apesar de não
existir essa previsão clara, como existe para o
leilão judicial, que a lei mesmo diz qual
é a preferência pelo leilão online, o leilão
ex-judicial, ele é, em grande maioria, realizado
também de forma online, justamente pela facilidade que
o leilão online proporciona.
O leilão online, ele proporciona que qualquer interessado
possa participar.
Então, não importa se você está em outro
estado ou até mesmo em outro país, basta
que você siga aquele procedimento, que você vai
poder arrematar o imóvel de sua preferência.
Para que você participe no leilão online, é
necessário que você se cadastre no site do
leiloeiro.
Quando você realizar esse cadastro no site do
leiloeiro, vai abrir um campo para você enviar
a sua documentação.
Essa documentação, na maioria dos casos, é enviada
para o próprio site do leiloeiro.
Você carrega a documentação no site do leiloeiro.
Existem alguns leiloeiros que pedem para que você
envie essa documentação por e-mail e alguns
raríssimos que pedem que você envie a sua
documentação por correios, mas são bem raros mesmo.
A maioria dos casos vai pedir para que
você digitalize a sua documentação no próprio site
do leiloeiro ou envie por e-mail e
aí basta que você tire uma foto da
sua documentação e carregue lá no site do
leiloeiro sem maiores problemas.
É preciso que você fique atento a esse
tempo de cadastro, porque quando você se cadastra
no site do leiloeiro, você envia a documentação,
o leiloeiro, ele precisa de um prazo para
analisar a sua documentação e esse prazo geralmente
fica entre 48 horas e 72 horas para
o seu cadastro ser liberado.
Você só vai poder oferecer um lance depois
que o seu cadastro for liberado.
Então fique atento para que você faça esse
cadastro com o máximo de antecedência que você
puder, para que você não deixe para cima
da hora e assim perca uma oportunidade muito
boa que você estava de olho.
Essa documentação que o leiloeiro vai pedir para
que você encaminhe é a documentação básica, identidade,
CPF, comprovante de residência.
Se você for casado, dependendo do seu regime
de casamento, pode ser que o leiloeiro também
peça para que você apresente a cestidão de
casamento e os dados do seu cônjuge.
Isso tudo é bem simples, sem maiores problemas.
Você vai realizar o cadastro, mandar os documentos
e o leiloeiro vai liberar o seu cadastro.
Quando o leiloeiro libera o seu cadastro, você
está apto para se habilitar para participar de
um leilão específico.
E aqui entra um detalhe muito importante, para
que você possa oferecer um lance em determinado
imóvel de determinado leilão, é necessário que você
esteja habilitado diretamente para oferecer lance naquele leilão.
Habilitação nada mais é do que um clique
no site do leiloeiro falando que você concorda
com as regras específicas daquele leilão.
Por que regras específicas daquele leilão?
Porque algumas particularidades podem mudar de um leilão
para o outro, como o prazo de financiamento,
se vai ser aceito, se não vai, em
quantas parcelas pode ser financiado, em quantas parcelas
pode ser parcelado, se aquele ali for um
leilão judicial, vai ter toda a designação do
número do processo que determinou aquele leilão, do
juiz que determinou aquele leilão, as partes daquele
leilão, o horário daquele leilão, isso tudo você
concorda quando você se habilita, quando você se
habilita você está concordando com a regra daquele
edital especificamente, do horário do começo e do
fim, do valor daquele leilão, do valor de
desconto e mais essas regras especificazinhas de cada
leilão.
Não deixe de se habilitar para o leilão
de seu interesse, por quê?
Porque você só pode oferecer um lance se
você estiver habilitado e fique atento também ao
prazo que o leiloeiro fala como limite para
habilitação em determinado leilão.
Tem uns leiloeiros que botam um prazo de
duas horas antes do leilão, outros leiloeiros que
botam um prazo de 24 horas antes do
leilão e depois daquele prazo, encerrou, ninguém mais
se habilita, só vai poder oferecer lance quem
está habilitado.
Tem muita gente que perde oportunidade, que está
de olho, oportunidade excelente porque esquece de se
habilitar e aí chega na hora do leilão,
não consegue se habilitar porque o prazo já
encerrou, não consegue oferecer um lance.
Fique atento a isso e faça sua habilitação
com o máximo de antecedência que você puder.
E aqui uma observação, não existe nenhum ônus
em se habilitar para um leilão, você pode
se habilitar em quantos leilões você quiser e
chegar na hora você não oferecer nenhum lance.
Isso não tem nenhuma penalidade pro rematante, por
quê?
Não existe uma obrigatoriedade de quem está habilitado
oferecer um lance, a habilitação é só um
requisito para que você possa oferecer um lance,
mas não é uma obrigatoriedade.
O que você não pode fazer é oferecer
um lance e depois desistir do seu lance.
O lance, via de regra, ele é irretratável,
você não pode cancelar o lance que você
ofereceu.
Então não faça um procedimento que muitas vezes
a gente se sente tentado a fazer quando
nunca participou de um leilão em algum leiloeiro
específico, que é, mandei minha documentação, o leiloeiro
aprovou a minha documentação, realizei a minha habilitação,
mas será que realmente eu vou conseguir dar
um lance aqui nesse leilão?
Posso aqui testar pra ver se vai dar
certo ou não e depois eu cancelo meu
lance?
Não, o lance é irretratável.
Se você der um lance, ninguém cobrir o
seu lance, aquele leilão vai encerrar e você
vai ser o vencedor daquele leilão.
Se você vencer um leilão e não realizar
o pagamento daquele leilão, você vai sofrer penalidades,
você vai ser multado, você pode ser proibido
de participar de outros leilões, você pode responder
até mesmo por crime, por fraudar um leilão.
Então fique muito atento a isso, só dê
um lance quando você tiver certeza de que
aquele imóvel é o imóvel que você quer,
mas se habilite em qualquer leilão que você
tiver interesse, mesmo que você depois da habilitação
faça uma análise mais profunda e veja, ah,
esse leilão aqui não é interessante, esse leilão
aqui pode sobrar alguma dívida pra mim e
eu não quero participar, não acho interessante nem
pelo valor de desconto que tá sendo oferecido.
E tudo bem, não existe qualquer ônus na
sua habilitação.
O leilão, ele vai acontecer todo de forma
online.
Então como é que funciona?
Você se cadastra, você se habilita, você oferece
lances.
Todas as outras pessoas que estão habilitadas para
aquele leilão específico também vão oferecer lances e
aí pode acontecer ou não uma disputa.
Como é que acontece essa disputa?
Vai ser um lance após o outro, sendo
o lance subsequente sempre maior que o lance
anterior?
Vai ter que sempre cobrir aquele lance anterior,
respeitando o incremento mínimo daquele determinado leilão.
Vamos ter aqui uma aula específica que a
gente vai falar sobre o incremento.
Mas saiba que o leilão online, ele tem
um prazo para começar e um prazo para
encerrar.
O que é muito comum em um leilão
online é que as pessoas interessadas, elas só
ofereçam lance nos últimos minutos para aquele leilão
encerrar.
Por quê?
Qual é a finalidade de fazer isso?
A finalidade é que você não levante concorrência
prévia para o leilão que você está interessado.
Vamos supor que aquele leilão ele vai ficar
aberto por 20 dias.
Você dê um lance oferecendo 10, 5 dias
para o leilão encerrar.
Você vai atrair concorrência para aquele leilão.
Pode ser que uma pessoa nem fosse olhar
para aquele leilão, que ela fosse olhar para
outros leilões daquele mesmo leiloeiro, mas quando ela
vê que tem um lance, ela já pode
pensar hum, esse leilão aqui é interessante, deixa
eu analisar aqui a documentação e ver se
eu também entro nesse leilão.
Então a finalidade de não oferecer lances com
muita antecedência é exatamente não levantar essa concorrência
prévia.
O que os investidores geralmente fazem?
Os investidores geralmente oferecem lances nos últimos minutos
antes do leilão encerrar.
Então é comum que até 15 minutos, 10
minutos antes do leilão encerrar, não tenha nenhum
lance, que os lances só comecem dali para
o final do leilão.
Exatamente para não levantar essa concorrência prévia.
E agora pode ser que você tenha se
perguntado, ah, então se um leilão, por exemplo,
fecha 15 horas, se eu oferecer um lance
às 14h59, vai ser o melhor dos mundos,
porque naquele último minuto vai ficar muito corrido
para uma pessoa oferecer um lance, é assim
que funciona?
Não.
Quando um leilão é online, ele tem uma
hora para fechar, como a gente acabou de
falar.
Vamos usar esse mesmo exemplo, que o leilão
vai encerrar 15 horas.
Se você oferecer um lance nos últimos 3
minutos para o leilão encerrar, o relógio, o
cronômico daquele leilão, vai acrescentar mais 3 minutos
para que mais pessoas possam oferecer um lance.
Então, por exemplo, não adianta você oferecer um
lance nos últimos 20 segundos, que o relógio
do leilão vai colocar mais 3 minutos para
que os demais habilitados naquele leilão possam cobrir
o seu lance.
O recomendado, então, é que você não deixe
para oferecer o seu primeiro lance nesses últimos
3 minutos, porque necessariamente o relógio vai acrescentar.
Se você quiser deixar para oferecer um lance
no final, faça ali entre 10 e 5
minutos para encerrar, mas também fique atento a
esse prazo, porque depende única e exclusivamente da
sua conexão com a internet.
Então se você não tiver confiança na sua
conexão com a internet, não deixe para oferecer
esses lances muito em cima da hora, porque
pode ser que você ofereça um lance, a
sua internet crave, o cronômico continua contando lá
no site do leiloneiro, aquele leilão vai encerrar
e você não vai conseguir mais, você está
fora daquela disputa.
Fique atento, então, a sua conexão de internet
também.
Depois do leilão, o procedimento também vai ser
feito todo de forma online.
Nós vamos estudar que quando um leilão encerra
positivo, isso é, quando tem um arrematante para
aquele imóvel, vai ser feito um auto de
arrematação.
Esse auto de arrematação, via de regra, ele
vai ser assinado pelo leiloneiro, pelo arrematante, se
for um leilão judicial, pelo juiz, se for
um leilão mesmo judicial, vai ser enviado para
o credor fiduciário.
E como é que você vai fazer essa
assinatura?
Você não precisa comparecer ao leiloneiro, ao escritório
do leiloneiro.
Ele vai te mandar por e-mail, você
vai imprimir, vai assinar e na maioria dos
casos ele vai pedir para que você mande
digitalizado.
Alguns poucos leiloneiros pedem que você mande a
sua documentação assinada por correios, mas via de
regra você vai mandar digitalizado, por e-mail,
tudo normal e o leiloneiro ali ele dá
o prosseguimento.
Como acontece o pagamento?
O pagamento você também não vai ter nenhum
contato com o leiloneiro.
Se for um leilão judicial, o leiloneiro ele
vai te mandar a guia de pagamento judicial
para que você pague até 24 horas após
a finalização do leilão.
Então você vai receber isso por e-mail,
você vai pagar essa guia de depósito judicial
e esse dinheiro ele vai direto para o
poder judiciário, vai ficar direto em uma conta
vinculada ao juiz que determinou aquele leilão.
Esse dinheiro do lance, no leilão judicial, não
passa pela mão do leiloneiro.
O que você vai pagar diretamente ao leiloneiro
é a comissão dele, os 5% lá
via de regra sobre o valor do lance
e essa comissão o leiloneiro vai indicar qual
é a forma que ele quer receber.
É normal que o leiloneiro coloque uma disposição
no edital que ele vai receber a comissão
dele através de um TED ou de um
DOC, então você vai fazer uma transferência bancária,
vai guardar o seu comprovante, vai enviar o
comprovante para o leiloneiro e tudo certo.
Se for um leilão ex-judicial, o leiloneiro
ele também vai te mandar a guia de
pagamento para que você faça o pagamento e
aí no edital do leilão ex-judicial vai
ficar estipulado como é que vai ser feito
esse pagamento, na maioria dos casos os bancos
eles colocam que o boleto vai ser emitido
pela empresa tal, então você vai receber esse
boleto que foi emitido por essa empresa indicado
no edital do leilão, vai pagar e aquele
dinheiro também vai direto para o credor fiduciário,
não passa pelo leiloneiro, para o leiloneiro se
da mesma forma vai pagar a comissão dele
da forma como ele preferir e que estiver
disposta em edital.
Então se o leiloneiro preferir receber por um
TED, ele vai colocar no TED o banco
dele, a conta dele, tudo certo para que
você faça esse depósito.
Esse aqui é mais um dos fundamentos para
acabar com aquela ideia de máfia dos leilões,
porque veja, acabei de falar que você vai
fazer todo o procedimento sem encontrar o leiloneiro
presencialmente em nenhum caso, se for um leilão
online, você não vai ter nenhum contato com
o leiloneiro, você vai fazer tudo de forma
remota, enviar tudo de forma online.
Já no leilão presencial vai ter dia e
local previamente divulgado no edital do leilão, essa
divulgação também vai ser pelo site do leiloneiro,
mas para que você ofereça um lance, você
vai ter que comparecer presencialmente ao lugar indicado
no edital daquele leilão.
Quando você chega num dia de um leilão
presencial, é comum que sejam distribuídas placas numeradas,
então vai ter o leiloneiro, ele vai falar
qual é o lodge que está indo a
leilão, qual é o imóvel que está indo
a leilão e o lance inicial que vai
ser por esse valor mínimo.
Então as pessoas vão levantando as placas e
assim vai acontecendo a concorrência, vai ter um
incremento para aquele leilão, cada vez que você
levanta a placa você está concordando em acrescentar
o valor do incremento para aquele leilão, até
que realmente o leiloneiro vai fazer aquele famoso
dore uma, dore duas, dore três, para encerrar
aquele leilão pelo maior lance que já foi
oferecido.
Quando você for participar de um leilão presencial,
se é que um dia você vai participar
de um leilão presencial, porque realmente hoje em
dia a prioridade é absoluta para o leilão
online, você deve verificar com o leiloneiro antes
de comparecer presencialmente no lugar se você precisa
levar alguma forma de pagamento, existem leiloneiros que
pedem para que você leve um cheque e
ali naquele momento você assine um cheque com
um sinal e aí depois no prazo de
24 horas, se for um leilão judicial, você
vai receber a guia de pagamento no seu
email para que você pague, se for um
leilão extrajudicial, uma guia para que você realize
o pagamento direto ao credor judiciário, então fique
atento a isso antes de comparecer a um
leilão presencial, porque pode ser que você chegue
lá, queira oferecer um lance e você vai
descobrir que seria necessário, se você ganhasse aquele
leilão, que você ali na hora já pagasse
um sinal através de um cheque e você
não levou cheque, então não adiantou nada você
ir.
Fique atento a isso, entre em contato com
o leiloneiro e veja como é que vai
ser a forma que vai ser realizada aquele
leilão.
E o leilão híbrido é o último tipo
de leilão que pode ser realizado.
Esse vai ser realizado simultaneamente de forma online
e de forma presencial, então os interessados em
participar de forma online, vão oferecer seus lances
de forma online exatamente da mesma maneira que
a gente acabou de falar aqui para o
leilão todo feito de forma online.
Quem quiser realizar seu lance de forma presencial,
vai comparecer presencialmente ao local indicado no edital
do leilão e vai realizar seu lance lá
de maneira presencial.
Nesse tipo de leilão vai existir um programa
que vai integrar os dois tipos de lance
oferecidos, então quem estiver online vai saber qual
é o lance que está sendo oferecido presencialmente,
quem estiver presencialmente vai saber qual é o
lance que está sendo oferecido de forma online
e vai ganhar o que for oferecido em
maior valor, independente se for de forma online
e se for de forma presencial.
Como é que você vai saber qual vai
ser o tipo de leilão realizado diretamente no
leilão de seu interesse?
Você vai verificar no edital do leilão?
O edital do leilão vai falar se aquele
leilão vai ser online, presencial ou híbrido.
Basta ler no edital que você vai saber
as informações.